[Music]
we are in the nus campus
and in front of one of the management of
fish building
we are standing on the project that
showing the
alternative green space that allow the
natural growth of the
planted or unplanted vegetation to
achieve a certain
level of the biodiversity and a certain
level of the sustainability
of these areas previously this
area was just a campus renown and it's a
very typical loan that having an
open area with just only one single
exotic species
so we just demarcated this area at the
beginning of the first two years time
we just let them grow up without any
human intervention that was the
beginning of
this project after this two years time
we determined that there's a lot of
biodiversity so this is already ten
years that
we made this garden and as you can see
it's like a forest
so it's early stage of the forest for
the next second stage what we prepare is
that
we want to make a more high level of the
biodiversity achieve
this small area based on
my research about the perceptions
acceptable degree of the
wildness in the urban green space
to the public i found that as long as
it's
green and as long as can see the sum of
the q2 care
people is uh all right i mean they can
accept it it's okay to be a little bit
wider
that gives me this kind of confidence
that where we can push more
cue to care is the action to showing
intentional gesture that we are care
about
this area one of the examples of this
gesture is we make a very
neat edge condition and then we also
wanted to intentionally put the
flowering plants in front of the focal
point and we also make comfortable
walking footpaths which may be
separate from this messy ecosystem that
one obviously needs a designer section
that
how we're gonna treat nation is more
accessible for the people and acceptable
for the people
we just started the bachelor of the
landscape architecture
we found that more and more people is
interesting over this field and so the
field
is not just about design it's a kind of
connect with the environment
when the nature is kind of mean to
achieve certain
target that we are trying to do it for
the sustainability of the
city we are living in
this ecological age so this is very
timely
gesture that we make of this department
and program to having on this
course i hope that the younger
generation has a more
systemic way to value it of this
green space and also how to using the
green space as a mean for
all the planning and other environmental
issues that we can tackle on
you